ich bin jeden moment tot
ich bin tot klasse ich bin gestorben ich
hab nicht mal ein jetpack fast alle
meine sachen sind weg hey hey wie soll
ich ihn daher zehn kommen ja cool
klasse toll gemacht luca super ich habe
alles verloren
sie hat aus meiner sicht überhaupt nicht
aus ein hoffnungsloser fall hat mit
diesem abend ein
da war so eine kiste bekiffte ist dort
so kurze damit rein
ich hab einen fackeln hab ich irgendwo
kann er stimmt ich habe keine kohle dass
das problem doch ich hab kohle
die habe ich nicht das manöver aber
sticks habe ich keine angst x6 habe ich
natürlich die fackeln hier wenig penis
gibt es viele
ich habe mir schon gedacht du bist nicht
so blöd eindruck shift und was wirklich
shift und ich denke er ist lang ich voll
komisch irgendwie mir egal so hier ist
noch frei brot brauche auf jeden fall
mich regt das einfach so oft dass man
das meinen dass mein bogen mit und
endlich kein einziges nelson bums direkt
ein fachvortrag fläche soll jedoch
gleich wieder runter
wie kann die denn ich bin schon wieder
20 minuten auf die piigs ich hab gar nix
lv solarpanel
im lv dollar panel dollar
a
das menge kohle das von einem engel glas
und zwar von jede menge geld
das gewaltverbrechen manche alle lag ich
jetzt brauche
cool cool cool dass koller sie kommt
dann noch dran kohle in den pulver
reiser oder kohle in den mails rater
geht auch dann hatte ich doch lieber
marcoule in den mails rater und bekommen
kohl das daraus so
generell brauche ich acht wie viele habe
ich noch ein
dafür habe ich vier maschinen blog sowie
generatoren
ich habe nicht so viel ich habe aber
noch ein randvolles
so habe ich eigentlich zwei inspection
services kann mir das einer von euch
sagen wieso habe ich zwei mein gott gut
freundlich braucht acht also so dann
dementsprechend so dass beide sind über
um 7
so weil 1 habe ich auch schon hier sehen
sich die einst das heißt freunde
wir machen eine höhlentour e-klasse luca
höhlentour hat man ja schon lange nicht
mehr
ihr müsst jetzt aber einfach mal ein
paar sachen rankommen kann daher
ich lasse euch hier allemal hier so
nicht nämlich mit dem zauberstab nämlich
auch mit 1000 bürger die hacker hätten
den aufruf ausgehen was hat sich denn
gestern noch mal gemacht
scanner dann die seria ist
ach ja der hat der hat was hat er denn
gemacht
nein ist aus versehen aufgedrückt der
hat sich so ein komisches dingsbums
gebaut
but i komm wir laufen jetzt noch richtig
richtig weit einfach freunde habe ich
denn ich verstehe das nicht ich meine
dass dingsbums dasselbe hat natürlich
eine dürre bielecki und ich muss das
aufladen wenn ich doch aber jetzt ein
jetpack mitnehmen zum beispiel also wird
man das legt sich jetzt auf
lade dich warum lässt sich das nicht auf
doch jetzt auf so wenn ich doch jetzt so
ein bett picknick mitnehmen
dann legt hat sich doch eigentlich
während der fahrt auf oder und das bad
müsste sich doch jetzt eigentlich ja das
lädt sie jetzt auch auf eher gut
standest du eigentlich alles geklärt
ich brauche jeden fall noch eine
spitzhacke und ich würde sagen da mach
ich mir gleich eine diamant spitzhacke
und zauberer die ziehen wir sind
verzauberten natürlich nicht 3
ich mache mir keine diamant spitzhacke
dafür sind mir diamanten die viel zu
wertvoll da mein lieber zwei rubinen
spitzhacken anstatt dass ich mir da so
eine diamanten spitzhacke war dann
kommen wollen wir zwei grüne noch
sind die ganzen generation
jaha luca trug so
komm ich ihn jetzt so eine kiste muss
man auf jeden fall auch immer mitnehmen
darf man natürlich nie vergessen und
crafting table verwicklung backpack
kommst netz wieder
vielleicht das jetpack ja auch noch mal
eben auf ich meine wenn jetzt tag ist
können wir auch noch zu fuß rumlaufen
ich war jetzt alle anderen fahren mit
zauberstäben und den ganzen scheiß
machen wir nicht während old school hip
star ja ja ja hat das jetzt bald mal
welche richtung sich nicht gern wir sind
noch nicht in diese richtung gegangen
dann will ich sagen gehen wir dann da
mal hin so ab
jetpack ihr kurz rüber geflogen und
weiter geht's möchten auch mein mein
ziel ist am ende eigentlich sollen so
eine nano legen sondern ich so mein ziel
erreicht in diesem kompletten let's play
mehr oder weniger muss er gab an ein
schloss ein bisschen weiter ich glaube
jetzt einfach mal dass ein grundschutz
mäßiger wo ja ich habe ihm zwei kumpels
sondern ein gesamt komme ich mit jetzt
einfach gegen
auch jetzt brauche ich hier schon wieder
soll
muss ich mir auch ohne witze mit diesem
megaprojekt dass man einfach so unnormal
träge geworden auch hier fahren die
rallye entsandt
einfach es regnet ja gerade eigentlich
deswegen sind auch so viele mops
realisieren strato
wir müssen unser ziel ist eigentlich
eine höhle zu finden
in der es muss nicht mehr heftige gänge
wegen essen ist sie muss ich meine geile
hülle sein es muss einfach nur viele
rohstoffe vorhanden sein das ist das
allerwichtigste dass spaß so mops mit
einem schlag zu töten
also freunde wir laufen weit weg ich
habe im bett vergessen man ja ich hab
ein jetpack das heißt wir können wir
noch auf jeden fall zurück fliegen
was diese blöcke sind das weiß ich auch
immer noch nicht ich weiß das habt ihr
mir alle in die kommentare geschrieben
und ich glaube es hat was mit ihnen zu
das ist auch wieder typisch minecraft
hier ist eine wüste das wüste und hessen
sind also das ist typisch minecraft
einfach dass beides nebeneinander ist
sondern region finde ich glaube ich auch
schön das erinnert mich so an wo ich
noch selber mal aktiv geschaut hat war
glaube ich
peet mit staffel irgendwas die waren
alle zusammen auf einem berg das so
unnormal geil dann war das geilste let's
play waa sie geschaut habe dann muss ich
echt sagen das hab ich dann bei twitter
gepostet wenn man irgendwas cool fand
ohne dabei jedoch aktiver zuschauer
mittlerweile ist das ja so dass die ich
mit sohn würde behandelt habe und ich
mit dem stumpf des nano 6 geschlagen
mittlerweile bin ich ja zeitlich so
verhindert dass ich gar nicht mehr
youtube gucken kann mehr oder weniger
wir müssen auf jeden fall eine höhle
finden wo noch keiner drin war einfach
vielleicht haben dann auch meine chance
auf diamanten nicht mal wir machen uns
einfach unten so einen gang auf diese
diamanten ebene oder wie das bafa ihk
fey alter das kann auch echt nicht wahr
sein
gruber chocolat hey was geht es bei euch
durchlauf gestiegen so gibt mir wird
jetzt sofort noch mehr kohle ja das land
platzierte fackel
was ist so lange bis dieser blöde
zauberstab hier endlich vorbei ist
ich meine ich mag den es war aber ich
bin in dieser abhängig davon dass mehr
wenn man die ganzen sachen sie selber ab
dann geht das auch schneller und
schneller geht das nicht würde jedoch
nicht aus dem zauberstab
ich muss mir zaubern auf jeden fall bei
bringe ich werde auf jeden fall coole
sachen bei simon und so den ganzen
anderen europa per pop-up ich glaube ich
ich müssen wir das endlich gar nicht
schreiben könnt ihr mir natürlich gerne
schreiben finde ich auch sehr cool aber
ich kann auch einfach die anderen fragen
ob man ihn denn wenn man mit mir
aufnimmt da frage man mal ein paar die
dann irgendwie mit mir aufnehmen wollen
oder so und dann frage ich mein fach
konzern machen bringe damit die bahn
zauberte bei uns okay dann mal weg wird
jetzt wieder ausgezogen
das doch auch so eine schöne wie sich
will ich mich auch glaube ich gerne
zufrieden fühlen so schön blühen viele
tiere okay wenn ich wenn ich keine tiere
mehr beim mégane aus wicker an
beim methanausstoß
lassen dass da steht einfach mal so ein
obsidian dinger luft kann ich da nicht
von oben gegen fliegende von jetpack
oder so ein paar euro möglich das ist
dass man ja cool ist einfach ja das
bringt es natürlich das hast du denn gut
ich es eigentlich ganz gut weil ich kann
jetzt level sammeln nicht immer level
ein level 30
und ich dachte es wenn du so eine schöne
pyramide probiert nicht immer level 30
dann kann ich mir dann auch eine diamant
spitzhacke verzaubern
wenn ich dann die eier habe dass die
dann auch mitnehmen und nicht wieder
verliere wegen bestimmten anderen
mitspielern hier ist das nicht das ist
die query von
alter ist das riesig das ist jetzt nicht
das doch war die query alter
das war die krimi von msi experte
hallo pc geht's dir gut ja die credit
hat ein bisschen war scheiße ja gut
irgendwann werden wir auch so etwas
ausrichten können freunde aber dafür
brauchen erstmal die höhle
nach alter ist das bitter man ist es
nacht und wir haben immer noch keine
höhle gefunden und vor allem ist es
nachts wir sind bei fast morgen
losgeflogen
egal wer ein bisschen die welt gesehen
egal ich kann jetzt auch noch ein
bisschen links fahren
diese ganzen steine die ich für mein
haus brauche basalt heiß her genau habe
ich frau 27 alter hut ist die sonne
verpackte kleine inseln des kleinen
höhle wo sie zu ende
alter wenn es nicht seine riesige höhle
ist erstaunlich aber wahr dass die hat
bisher nur ein gang
ich wollte ihnen die paar sachen ab die
ihr sind was ist das eigentlich des
körpers achten die mineral kommen wieder
komplett durcheinander jetzt das so gar
nicht gespielt hier nur vor wie nach mit
irgendwem anders spielen nämlich hier
ein bisschen als erfolg ob er mich dann
hier wieder ein bisschen zu recht weist
es ist nicht negativ betrachtet aber nur
hier willst du meine deswegen ich glaube
ich mache gleich einen platz so in das
gleich 26 minuten oder so und dann las
ich von ihm hoch in der zwischenzeit
sucht derzeit der zauber kann zum
beispiel
komme und nimmt damit den
für noch reisen abbauen brauchen wir ja
für die event services ab geht's weiter
richtung wohnt
mama mama
oh mann
da hat man lange
wow das war's
cool
echt klasse ballon toll gemacht am
liebsten wenn ihr fahrzeug dabei hätte
wichtig jetzt angst und ich dachte
irgendwas geheimnis oder so da unten
sind schade sie brauche ich glaube ich
zum zaubern haben wir einige geschrieben
tintenfische zombies sowie
gebt mir erfahren
was gibt
ich muss atmen
kohle
und 2
dabei der ballon hier sind wir mit heißt
ich muss da ja festland so und ich
glaube keinen folgt ist über diesen
ganzen weg hier gegangen den ich gerade
gegangen bin
diesen weg gegangen bin oder doch die
werden ja ich kann mir schlecht
vorstellen dass irgendwie schon leute
waren
was sind das eigentlich alle schmeißt
man brot drauf
das verstehe ich jetzt gar nicht dass
eine falle oder so
habe ich jetzt echt gedacht eigentlich
ich meine warum ist es denn hier sonst
so alles ausgeschildert so was gehört
aber das ist eine time falle so ich geh
so rein und zehn sekunden später
explodierte das letztlich gleich alles
noch mal ganz frech sein einfach diese
häuser abbauen von denen sind wie aha 3
was machst du da so achtet schild deine
frage da ist wieder so ein festungs ding
vielleicht habe ich mich dafür gewachsen
fühle
es ist auch ihm die gerade das macht ist
ich bin weg ich gehe noch ein bisschen
enthüllen der freunde des ach so so ist
das
ich bin jeden moment tot
ich bin tot klasse ich bin gestorben ich
hab nicht mal ein jetpack fast alle
meine sachen sind weg hey wie soll ich
ihn daher zehn kommen
klasse toll gemacht luca super ich habe
alles verloren fast lohnt es sich da
hinzulaufen das ist jahre weg ich bin ja
geflogen
dann hatte ich damit ich hatte
eigentlich nichts mit oder ich hatte
einen zauberstab mit natürlich mein name
selber
mein name selber als ich gebe jetzt
einfach mal auf mit den sachen auch wenn
ich da reinkommen übels zu rüstung sagte
es gar nicht so schwer eigentlich sehr
gut jetpack ist doof backpack ist auch
durch kern des bag ist übelst of the
pack ist zwar nicht so schwer aber guckt
euch kennen es bäcker muss wieder dieses
zeug anbauen
dann muss ich wieder ganz viele strings
haben
ach ich hab noch 50 na gut freuen uns
erstmal kath ich habe ich eine
motivation wenn ich jetzt ist auch so
mancher com schickt die welt